i was born in cuba and i posed as an
italian
i paid off the mob guys and just things
started happening
and growing before i knew it i was
driving the captain of the gambino crime
family around
very colorful character by the name of
greg the palm what point did you know
your job as an fbi agent you were hooked
on saying this is exactly what i thought
it was gonna be
you know it was immediately just that
whole movement of being an undercover
and fooling people to believing the
person you're trying to portray well
undercover became my home
greg de palma is the guy who appeared in
that famous photograph with frank
sinatra
carlo gambino was here like a real real
mafioso where his loyalty was to la cosa
nostra over family where he followed the
code to the t was he known as somebody
like that
he had a big mouth that was great for
the fbi he loved to talk we love to
listen
he's looking for ways to exploit you
that's what he does with everybody
is there a training for that meaning is
more caught or todd
they're out there committing crimes as
kids then they wind up going to jail but
jail is like going to oxford
in the mob is total accountability
as to where you're at why are you doing
this is that his dna or is that the dna
the la cosa nostra where they're always
looking at how can i get more money of
this guy in front of me
yes absolutely that is the dna with that
money in the mob
always flows up it never flows down it's
all about making money
you think that part can ever change
there's nothing but criminals that's all
they are
[Music]
my guest today is jack garcia aka
jack falcone who was an undercover fbi
agent 26 years of which
24 years he was undercover and for many
different
uh uh heist many different projects that
he had whether it was going against the
russian mob i think the asian mob he did
stuff with colombians
he did stuff with the mexican cartel but
his biggest uh
uh story that ended up being a book
nowadays that many people have read
is him playing the undercover you know
guy that's running a business out of
florida that comes to new york
and eventually one of the couples from
the gambino family takes a liking
into him he gets into the family he's
there for three years three years later
he penetrates the gambino family ends up
arresting 32 mothers convictions of 32
mobsters
including the top members of the post
john gotti gambino crime family
with that being said jack garcia thank
you so much for being a guest on
valuetainment
oh thank you for having me what an honor
thank you so did i miss anything there
did
anything i know you got a lot of awards
i know you've done a lot of great work i
know fbi loves you for the service that
you did
did i miss any part of this story when i
went through it well the
the main part that you missed patrick
was the fact that i was born in cuba
and i post as an italian yeah something
that at first
i didn't even believe that i could pull
it off but i think the crazy part that's
the crazy part so
so let's get right into it first of all
just so everybody knows uh
you know you know you're somebody that
came up i mean your story you watched
the movie serpico and then
you know you were inspired that that
that kind of inspired you to want to get
into the world so
why don't you tell us a little about
your upbringing on how you went to the
fbi
all right i was born in cuba actually uh
i lived under communism on the fidel
for about three years before we were
able to leave in 1961
and we came here we didn't speak uh a
word of english and
uh my proud my father had a job in new
york
actually at three in order to get us you
know
that this was going to be a temporary
hold that we were going to go back
to cuba when this banana republic was
over well needless to say that banana
republic is still there
so we um decided to stay in america
learn english and then i went on going
to a school up in washington heights uh
new york
and then we moved to the bronx or i went
to a catholic school
and there's where i started playing
football and i had the opportunity to
get
several scholarships and went to the
university of richmond and it was there
where i saw the movie serpaco and i knew
that that moment in time
i wanted to be into law enforcement
um it was kind of like a cool guy no al
pacino
long haired beard had the pretty girl
with the motorcycle and
an old sheep english dog to add to that
so i said this is what i want to do
but unfortunately back in the 70s nobody
was hiring
and the fbi refused to return my call so
what happened in 1976 or so
or the end of 75 i was watching
univision
and i saw this american non-native
spanish-speaking fbi agent
saying they were looking for spanish
speakers in the bureau
so i called the bureau right away and i
said look you got me you got my
application
i'm ready to go i meet the bill they got
back to me and said well you're not a
an american citizen so i became an
american citizen which is one of the
most proud moments of my life
and then i told them i said now i have
it let's get this going and in 1980
i became a special agent of the fbi now
let me ask you this right prior to that
what were you doing
before you became a special agent well
because i couldn't land a job in the
police department i wound up working in
some colleges
as director of testing then i got
involved actually got into
the police department at union county
prosecutor's office
but it was short-lived i was only there
about a year and then the fbi came
calling and
of course the rest is uh i have the
dream of my life job
i love it i love the fact that it is a
dream of your life job now
jack if i was in high school with you
who were you in high school if we were
in 10th grade 11th grade who who was
jack falcone
well at first jack
he's always a jovial guy you know i
break balls i
i i like hanging around with a bunch of
the guys have fun
i played sports i didn't have a weight
issue like i developed later in my
bureau career
so i i'm always an outgoing social
person
so i i was not a bully but i actually
protected those who bullet
you know that were bullied and uh and
that was the kind of guy people kind of
gravitated to me because of my size
i was this big mama luke 6'4 back then i
was around 240 250
and you know it was uh some kind of guy
that people gravitate to
makes sense so you bullied bullies is
what you did that is correct
okay and that that apparently didn't
change for the rest of your life you
enjoyed bullying bullies
well yeah i guess yeah so you're right
interesting okay
so now you go you go into the fbi you
got your dream job you're excited about
it
at what point do you get some of these
assignments that leads you to working
with the mob how soon did you get a big
assignment
well keep in mind that hoover died in
the in 72.
so the bureau did not really mirror the
demographics in our society
so here i come in this kid who speaks
spanish fluently
the kid doesn't look like an fbi agent i
didn't look your typical guy or dressed
alike
i grew up in havana i was grew up in
washington heights and the bronx
so i had a little something with it and
right around that time the fbi
got involved in working narcotics which
was the early 80s
so i was the perfect guy here i am i
speak spanish fluently
i know the streets i'm able to i'm a
social person
so i immediately started working cases
that were involving narcotics
and that's kind of where i uh i found my
little niche
in the fbi and and okay so when that
did take place what was your first
project that you got in and when it
happened was it kind of like
you were a fiend saying i'm hooked i i
want to do more
i'm in love with like at what point did
you know your job as an fbi agent you
were hooked on saying
this is exactly what i thought it was
going to be you know it was immediately
i went up work in a long-term national
security case so i really
can't discuss it you know patrick and
and i apologize for that but it was
where
i was working on the cover i was living
on my own i had a fake
identification just the way that cloak
and dagger
just that whole movement of being an
undercover and fooling people to
believing
the person you're trying to portray it
was just so
uh enticing to me and it was became like
my adrenaline drug
it was something that i drew my high my
my this is what i want to do
and i just couldn't wait to do it more
and again because there weren't that
many people who spoke the language like
i did i was a shoo-in so i just started
growing from one case to the other
each with each case i looked as a
challenge
and i enjoyed working with the men and
women in the fbi
uh so it was a perfect fit it was my
little niche
some guys are good maybe working
wiretaps other goods and surveillance
well undercover became my my home
so at what point after you became an fbi
agent 1980 did you get the call for
dealing going undercover with the mob
well how many years later
oh it was back the first time i got the
call was in the year 2000 2001
because again all my expertise was
working narcotics
either posing as a drug dealer a
transporter
a money launderer then i started doing
police corruption cases
murder for hires asian organizers so i
was all over the map
i never worked traditional organized
crime
actually it was all new to me because i
here i am you know with my language
skill
this was my little place to go so i
worked the russian case and one of the
agents in that russian case said
listen we are have a situation up in the
bronx we have a strip club
and that's being shaken down by some
albanians and some wise guy you
interested
so i said well what do you want me to do
you know and he said uh
well we want you to go in there maybe do
some payoffs
and see where it takes us to but pretty
much take the albanians out
well i said yes it was the latter part
of my career and
next thing you know yes i paid off the
mob guys to keep the albanians away and
just things started happening and
growing
before i knew it i was driving the
captain of the gambino crime family
around
that's how it got started got it and
this is in 2000 when you're doing that
this was 2010 2000
when i heard we may be doing this but
that christmas time is when i paid the
mob guy to keep the albanians away
the did the the strip club have anything
to do with john a light was he involved
at all or no
no not johnny a light who was involved
originally the captain of the crew that
i infiltrated
is a very colorful character by the name
of greg de palma
greg de palma is the guy who appeared in
that famous photograph
with frank sinatra carlo gambino and the
others
now also greg the palmer was the owner
of this
club that featured all the headliners
frank sinatra
uh dean martin sammy davis sonny and
cher
the who's who back in the late 70s were
playing at this marble
joint so he was a quite known celebrity
he had been
in jail for shaking down scores the
famous nightclub in new york city
that howard stern made famous so when he
came out
he reclaimed the strip club that we were
working and said this is my strip club
it's on record with me whoever is here
now which was another gambino
they wound up surrendering to him and at
first we were a little leery with greg
because greg is the kind of guy who's a
big talker
he loved to talk and we in the fbi loved
to listen so it was like a perfect match
we kind of hitched our wagon to him and
next thing you know like i said i
started becoming friendly with him
i started seeing what he was doing i was
trying to identify who the hierarchy of
the gambino
the post john gotti gambino organization
was
and it really brought me into more of a
going from a victim somebody paying
money to keep the mobs away and the
albanians to now becoming one of them
and that's how i wound up going there
from that i became
i got put on record with them and i
became an associate
in the gambino crime family at what
point did they start trusting you where
they said you know
like was there a tipping point was there
an event when they said
you know this is no longer a friend of
mine this this is somebody we want to
make a friend of
ours you know at what point did that
happen well a very much it was
life is all about timing patrick as you
know i mean
it just so happened that i filled the
void greg the palmer's son who was also
a made guy
who tried to kill himself in prison he
lost his son his confidant
and i kind of became his son so i was at
the right place at the right time and
then he started
uh really telling me a lot more of the
past
he started telling me about some of the
issues that were happening in the
gambino crime family
as to who was moving for jockeying for
power
who is getting straightened out why this
person should be straightened out
so all of that valuable intelligence was
great help for the fbi
so what happened is he just started
making me part of his crew
but it was an exhaustive operation i
mean
disguise talking about it sounds like
well it's kind of simple but
it was mentally draining the fact that
this man had so much demand
i mean i could remember one time i was
working another caper down in florida
my phone ring and at that time we had
the next telephones
and i hear his voice and he had this
raspy
voice kind of like a robert logia voice
and he would say
jackie boy pick up the phone so i was
working on something i just let it go
when i came home the next day he cuts me
in and he says uh
where were you yesterday i said i was
doing down on something in florida
so he said when i called you why didn't
you answer i said well greg i was a
little tied up he goes
don't you ever do that because how do i
know you weren't arrested
how do i know you're not talking or
wearing a wire right now
so the mob i learned something that they
did not teach me
in uh while preparing for this case that
there is so much accountability for
it it's not like when you're dealing
with a bad guy
a drug dealer and all of a sudden this
drug dealer
is you don't have to tell them where you
have where you've been what you do the
week before
in the mob is total accountability
as to where you're at why you're doing
this but i also
learned the hard way from then on that
any time he called no matter what i was
doing
i was going to pick up including when my
mother-in-law passed away i was at the
wake and sure enough the phone goes off
and it's greg the palmer
now i could of course not tell him that
i was
awake because i could just imagine the
boys will come into an
and you know have my aunt and my wife's
aunt say well
how long have you been in the fbi you
know so i i didn't but i went outside i
took the phone
that i want to take that call absolutely
not but i took that call because i knew
it would have set me back
so this is the kind of thing that was
with greg he would call me sometimes at
three in the morning
not just me everyone in the crew and he
says hey you watching tnt
rio bravo is on oh i love that movie
john wayne is great
and i'm going do i really need to hear
this at three o'clock in the morning
but that was almost a form of the phone
call at 3am had nothing to do but to
find out your level of loyalty to him
absolutely got it absolutely it was all
what do you think about that what do you
think about that like
you you because you know when you work
under somebody like that
it's it you know it's it's it's it comes
with a price
right it comes with a price of constant
non-stop accountability
how did you process all of this of
having to win the loyalty and the trust
well i knew that that's part of the
system that's part of kosa nostra
that's what it's all about there is no
lone wolves out there
if you are on record and you're put on
record
and you are using and you're flying
under that
uh umbrella of uh protection of that
particular family
you have to adhere to the rules you have
to stay in contact
because it's all about with them control
you stay in contact they know if you're
making money
if you're making money you're kicking up
money because as you know patrick money
and the mob
always flows up it never flows down so
it's all about
making those benjamins with these guys
and and the reason there is that
accountability
if you're going down to florida like i
did many times because i was working
other cases i would come back with a
little taste
by that i mean an envelope with a couple
of thousands in it maybe i'll come back
with some of the stolen merchandise that
we claim
that we have when in reality we're
forfeited jewelry
and i would say here you earn a little
so i i it's all about
the mob of making money it isn't about
your personality and as jovial as you
think you may are or
great storyteller or this and that if
you're not making
money for the mob you're not even going
to be anywhere near it because it's all
about them
sucking the life form out of you now
when you were there in 2000 who was the
boss in 2000
well when i got there the boss was
unknown
we found that the acting boards was
arnold scutieri
who was a loyalist to john gotti john
gotti jr
and was part of the triumvirate that
they had
of that family but then arnold gutierrez
took the nod
of being the acting boss and then came
the underboss which was
anthony magalli and then the uh
concierie was uh jojo corrazzo those
were the three
that we didn't know as to who was
running it because originally
they said it was john gotti jr then
peter gotti
and then when arnold took over as the
acting boss
he ran that organization got it got it
and
so uh so 2002 2004 you're spending all
this time with
uh the palma are you driving him around
is he the one that you're driving around
yes i want how it worked is his son who
tried to commit
suicide at the prison this because he
too was arrested in the scores case okay
and also the one down in atlanta georgia
i think it was called solid gold some
big strip club down there where all the
celebrity stars and uh and athletes
would go
he got arrested with greg there was
rumors that craig was cooperating
and greg arranged it that he would meet
with his son craig and pretty much
challenged him and said
you're a disgrace not only to the family
name you're a disgrace to kosa nostra
so what happened was they found him in
his
um cell hung so greg the palmer when he
came out of prison
he requested a one of those uh
released compassionate release and craig
the palmer was released
and put in a nursing home in westchester
now the irony of that is craig obama
went to all these nursing homes and
found one
and he specifically told the uh the
director of the nursing home that there
was not going to be any mob stuff
and the reason why everybody knew greg
de palma was a gangster
because of his westchester premier
theater days
so what happens within a week we had all
our meetings
at the nursing home all the wise guys
will come in there
and my heart ached when you see the
family members
looking at their elderly uh uh family
members
and surrounded by all these gangsters
who are either taking action
or or paying tribute payment to the mob
so greg de palma wound up running his
old operation he was
what i thought a good father or was he a
good
gangster because he was loving his son
and taking care of him but you know
it was a little weird because it was
also kind of selfish on greg
because it was known out there that
greg's son cooperated
and that was a reflection on him so but
of course
craig de palma's story was not that he
was cooperating
but instead it was the marshals who
killed him
i mean as outrageous that was that's
what he uh
he was putting out there in order to
cover himself in
in the gambino crime family what was he
it was he a
like a real real mafioso where his
loyalty was to la cosa nostra over
family where
he followed the code to the t was he
known as somebody like that
greg the palmer was brilliant in this
regard
yes he had a big mouth but again like i
said earlier
that was great for the fbi he loved to
talk we love to listen
but the interesting thing about greg and
he told me this in confidence
when you make money in the mob you have
to kick up
you kick up to your soldier if you're
reporting to a soldier
you kick up to your skipper and then the
skipper kicks up to the administration
okay what greg de palma told me is he
gave more
than the normal amount because he always
felt that the more you give will keep
him in social graces
with the administration in case he
screwed up and greg the palmer
was known for that so he did play the
cozy nostra rules where he gave money
to his bosses in excess just in case he
messed up
they were going to leave him alone out
of it or maybe just you know uh
let him walk interesting so he had the
wisdom there to know that
let me make sure the people above me are
happy so when they're not paranoid and
two
i keep getting the favors and the
benefit uh was he a decent earner
himself or was he more of an
enforcer no he was a very good earner he
had a lot of construction companies up
in westchester
that were on record with him he had
control of a lot of union
uh greg the palmer was like i said he
was a celebrity and it was kind of weird
too patrick because when we would go out
to dinner
and we would go to these fancy
restaurants in westchester
honest people you could tell there was
successful businessman
older would come to our table just to
shake hands with greg de palma
and reminisce about the great times that
they had at westchester
premier theater and greg the palmer
would take their calling card their
business card
and you could see him looking at that
and saying how do i get in this guy's
pocket
how do i what can i get out of this guy
in the future
by the end of the day sometimes you have
20 uh business cards
and he was always thinking he was a true
close nostra of
always thinking of where to make money
how to rob money in every regard
is is that is that his dna or is that
the dna the course co
la cosa nostra where they're always
looking at how can i get more money of
this guy in front of me
yes absolutely that is the dna with that
it's all about making money
you know and it's kind of funny when
when you
hear them and you see them constantly
it's always looking for angles it's
always looking of
how did i get over on this how do i put
and the way they work is quite genius is
they put you on record
they think that you or your business
establishment
is going to be benefit from it and that
no one will mess with it
well along with that comes you got to
pay
and along with that comes that now you
own a restaurant okay so
where are you getting your produce where
are you getting your wines
where you getting your linen who's doing
your garbage
they got the guys so they'll put these
people in place
and every place that they put in people
they put in
of course they're kicking back to the
mob so it's just
the way they work it's a constant
money-making organization
of every way that they can because
that's what it's all about with them
it's all about the greed and that's all
i think i was able
to get into them because of the greed is
you wave a little money you make
yourself to be the goose that laid the
golden egg
and there you go you have it now
a question for you about that when
you're talking about you know
hey you give me some money i'm going to
protect you the mob of the 80s is very
different than a mob of the 2000 because
piston came and cleaned house himself
from 76 to 81 i believe he was there for
like five years and 10 months
whatever pistons timeline was as an
undercover agent so
the the days of if somebody messes with
you we're going to take them out
you can't necessarily do that in the
2000s 2002.
so what is the business model if no one
fears you what do people fear that
you're going to do to them if you're not
going to take their lives
well the mob has definitely morphed
itself from way back in the old days
they come to realize that leaving bodies
on the street is bad for business
okay so they know that so they they yes
they
they are careful they like to operate
more in the gray area like strip clubs
or those corrupt union officials that
they go in they're not as open
shotgun plan like they were in the old
days to try to shake down
everybody and everything because they
know that people are wise to them
so it's kind of a catch-22 for them they
know that the mob runs on fear
but if they can't beat you up and they
can't kill you
how is that fear going to be generated
exactly so it does revert to sometimes
to old-fashioned beatings
you know where they just come they'll
beat you up tune you up and tell you
they're coming back
but then they're also very careful that
they you're going to call the cops and
put them in jail
so it's a delicate dance that the mob
does now
and takes that extra precaution of
of really doing background on an
individual company
or person to see if they're the kind of
people that you could approach
because one false move lands you in jail
for extortion
yeah but but i'm trying to see again
that business model in 2002
with the technology and where we're at
beating people up you come beat
the person up that person calls the cops
the next time you're coming to collect
taxes or whatever you're going to be
collecting
they record they turn it in your fake
you
even the beating up stuff i mean yeah
i'll take a beating one time two times
the person who calls them up you know
it's so so
it's a dramatic shift in business model
for it not to be that
uh effective so so let me ask you i
asked a question about
de palma being a earner you said he's an
earner was he also a capable guy was he
also a guy that was
capable of you know crossing the line
and you know handling the highest level
of job if needed
well the way it was explained to me when
i was proposed by greg de palma
how it works is they really the mob
looks for earners guys are gonna make
money
now if you are a person who plays by the
rules
keeps their mouth shut is capable of
violence
could do time okay you get proposed
to be put into this life but not
everybody is a killer
they have their own shooters how they
work is you could be called upon
to do something whether it's dig a grave
drive a getaway car
do a blocked car with the police
sometime and some place they may call
you
but unlike what the glamorization of
hollywood
not everybody's a killer not everybody
had to kill somebody to get straightened
out
okay there are a lot of guys who don't
because these guys who are making big
time money which with the mobs about yes
they do have their shooters but not that
so keeping as far as greg is concerned
he never opened up to me about any
murders
simply because in his teaching of me of
mob ways
he says once that bullet leaves the gun
you never talk about it
so it's like why would he talk about
that unless he's that dumb to say if he
was involved
but what we do know about greg de palma
he was in nino gagi's crew
it was the same crew of roy demaio so
yes could he have been involved in
something you know roy the male was just
a sadistic killer
so who knows what he did but as far as
with me
he never led me on to believe that he
was involved
nor did he brag that he was involved in
any killings
yeah only reason i'm asking is because
when i was sitting down with sammy
uh uh uh you know an interview with john
eli john elite said
ask anybody i've never seen john gotti
senior kill anybody
john always had people like me kill
people right now that's john a light
saying
then i went and brought that up to sammy
sammy said
let me put it to you this way gotti if
he had to i don't know if he did or not
because you know sammy's such a true
mafioso he's not gonna
even if he knows the answer he wouldn't
say because it's not his style to do
that because he
still fully uh uh respects the code what
it was obviously minus what happened
years ago he said don't get it twisted
john gotti is very very capable
because if he needed to do something he
would do it he's not somebody that you
want to think that he wouldn't do it
and then you hear john gotti jr when
they
asked him about sammy even though
there's obviously a big following out
between those families years ago even
john gotti said
sammy the bull if there's one thing
about sam you have to respect he's a
true mafioso
everyone knew he was capable so that's
what i'm asking is the part was the palm
of somebody that was a capable person
that he could have done something
you know or was he just the guy that was
making money from what i know he was a
money maker
okay you know he was strictly the money
maker he had the west chester premier
theater
but he also had access to shooters just
like what you mentioned why get your
hands dirty
when you can get somebody to do that for
you makes sense
makes sense with uh uh with that part by
the way do you notice a commonality
amongst those who are earners that had a
very very high
level of charm charisma persuasion
sales negotiation and and at the same
time the model was have people around
you that everyone feared
but you stayed the good guy so was
trying to stay the good guy you know
versus you have the bad cops around you
know the whole good cop bad cop
obviously this is uh
they're definitely far from being cops
but did you notice the main earners were
always protected and the best of the
best at
charming charismatic and attractive and
persuaders
oh absolutely spot on with that these
guys were
more polished like in the in the mob
there's your gangsters
and they're your racketeers racketeer is
a polish guy
if you are an individual who makes a lot
of money
you do surround look you're only allowed
to exist
because they let you exist and they
guard you
to exist so obviously you're going to
have the muscle
around you and you could also call on
that muscle
because if you're working with the mob
by all means
that they're going to say there's a
problem he's not going to get his hands
dirty
he'll go see a skipper or his soldier
and say look we got an issue
here they'll handle that forum you know
you notice a trend with that
um you know i i sat down with leonetti
and leonetti would tell me stories about
scarfo you know his uncle and
how scarfa was and then i sit down with
ralph natalie
and raf natalie will tell stories
different stories of scarfo right and
what what he was saying ralph natalie is
definitely not a fan of
phil leonetti and phil leonetti is just
he wants to have nothing to do with the
mob he wants to just
live the life that he lives and he wants
to have nothing to do with molino none
of those guys et cetera et cetera
great but they watched and they heard
stories being told of the people prior
to them
right when scott when leonetti's around
scarface scarfa would tell stories let
me tell you how this was and let me tell
you how this wasn't
even one time they went and met
myrlansky and there was a certain
connection there with lansky and natalie
has a lot of stories of a
skinny razor and all these other stories
that come up and you keep hearing about
these guys right
what stories of which personalities did
you know uh uh de palma tell you stories
of people in the past i'm sure he had
stories about
gotti i'm sure he had stories about
different people but what were some of
the stories that stuck with you
from the people in la cosa nostra i'm
not talking about sinatra stories dean
martin stories
we can get into that here in a minute
i'm talking specifically from the mob
life
yeah one thing about greg he was very
close to paul castellano
paul castellano put him in uh actually
proposed him
for a membership uh so he had this
closeness to he was also
enamored with john gotti actually told
me that when john gotti was in prison he
took care of john gotti
he said he bought him a hat because he
sometimes was called chief
and he it was a white hat with the word
chief on it
he said that he would take care of him
feed him during the final
days and everybody knew that that that's
what greg so he had this fondness
greg was kind of like a a brown noser
you know when it came to power he wanted
to surround himself with the power
in order to be protected by this power
now
grant you you look at uh sammy um i'm
sorry you look at paul castellano
you look at him i know he was very close
with a lot of the old-timers
one guy in particular was rudy santa
bello rudy santa bello killed the police
officer actually did time
and beat it through the supreme court
and then he came out and we used to go
to his social club
and meet with rudy who was this little
tiny person he used to call him
handsome rudy but a very powerful guy
who i was a captain
in the west side in the genovese family
so
greg circle was more of the old-timers
and none of these guys sat around and
bragged like i whacked this guy i killed
this guy
they subscribed to never talk about it
whether they did or don't
but we all assume that they had the
power to do that
because that is what close and holster
is all about
that maybe they don't get their hands
dirty but somebody else will
but he talked about about john gotti jr
he talked uh very much about how john
was
great he mourned every year at his uh
the data john
passed away um he was always
felt like devastated that john and he
was looking forward
for junior to come out as were we but
the problem is junior got hit with the
curtis leewa
uh charges and they kept him in in jail
so
greg actually made a phone call with an
fbi phone that he contacted
the family of john gotti jr saying hey
you know when is he getting out
and and all of that and they said they
had some problems with him
so they there was always this thing with
greg
and others that it was always trying to
get to the top and do whatever
it was necessary in fact when i was out
there with him uh and we
charged arnold schwutieri the acting
boss and mcgalley
he had um arnold schuteri and alfonsiska
called fonzie who was also a captain in
the gambinos
they shook down this very well to do a
guy
and they took his american express black
not platinum but black guard and there
they went on a spending spree with their
wives
to vegas and then after like 20 000
being spent they cut the card off
and we have it on tape because i was
wearing the recorder
when they're calling in they're saying
you tell this guy to reactivate his car
that's an embarrassment to
me that this card was cut off my and
these guys were like kids in the candy
stores their wives were doing manny
patties hairdo
they were shopping in the malls of the
uh of the casinos
it's it was just insane of the abuse
that they did
but again there goes greg kissing up
to the bosses so he would be okay with
them
as opposed to a guy who sits quiet and
then when it comes to take somebody out
they say well what good is this guy he
doesn't put
any money in my pocket i mean i remember
i
sold i i we came up with a scheme of uh
giving plasma tvs
and this actually happened which i think
you'll find it amazing so instead of
buying it uh a plasma tv i told them i
fell off the back of the truck and my
guys got it
so we give it to arnold schwarteri now
arnos gutierrez home
watching the sopranos now do you
remember the scene where robert leogia
with feech la mana comes out of prison
and things have changed and he's a
little threatening to tony soprano
because he was old school he didn't like
the way things were worked yeah so they
set them up
by putting and storing these plasma tvs
in the garage
and then drop a dime to the probation
officer
and boom he gets arrested uh again feet
lamanna
well what happened is greg de palma
calls me in the morning he says i gotta
see you
i says you're not gonna believe what
happened yesterday i know it's true but
i gotta ask you anyway
is that television stolen i go what do
you think greg
well i think i went to the store of
course the story goes i knew it
last night i got a call from the boss
he's watching that damn soprano show
and they talking about these plasma tvs
because he too was on parole
and he says get this thing out of my
house and get it out of there now
they yank the tv out of the wall just
for fear
so you talk about life imitating art
that was it
that was a perfect example so you know
so this is again greg
immediately volunteers when i told him i
had a couple that fell off the back of
the truck
let's give it to the boss you know
that's the way he
always buttered up everybody and he was
a master at
i mean he would see you patrick and he'd
be thinking how do i get in your
pocket how do i get in your business you
know and then he'll say okay he's
looking for ways to exploit you that's
what he does with everybody
because that's the nature of the beast
with these guys that's natural dude
that's not just
let me ask how do they get tr is there a
training for that or no you just see
somebody do it and you learn it and you
pick it up meaning
is is more caught or taught you know
it's something i think growing up in
these neighborhoods
these guys are not boy scouts as you
know they're out there committing crimes
as kids
then they wind up going to jail or jail
is like going to oxford
to these guys they're sitting around
prison they're talking about
scams here scams that they got in the
future
there's always a way to make your money
but it's in their dna
i've gone out with greg de palma to the
big man shop
that they had in new york city called uh
uh
anyway it skips me this beautiful store
they had on fifth avenue right we walk
in
i'm looking at clothes right here's greg
the palmer sticking ties
socks down his pants i go what are you
doing so he goes what do you mean what
i'm doing i said we're going to take a
pinch over here you're robin
i'll buy them for you give them to me he
goes nah forget that he goes jackie this
is what we do
you know this is who i am so it's
their dna they are thieves they are
criminals and they could be putting on
their fedoras
they could be pious men with fedoras and
45s
but they're nothing but criminals that's
all they are interesting and they're
looking to get in people's pocket
and without any remorse you think that
can ever change with them you think that
part can never change
no and i think i think i'm probably the
only guy who feels that the mafia is
going to come back
and i'll tell you why in the fbi the
investigative priorities
of organized crime is it's so low i mean
right now we have terrorism
uh cyber uh foreign counter intelligence
it's not even in the top ten where when
i was working and we were in the top ten
now what happened is they consolidated
five squads
into three squads and they got rid of a
lot of guys on the task force
so what do you think is going on if
there's nobody there
to pursue these guys yeah they're doing
what they're supposed to we are they're
a criminal secret society
they've crawled back under the rocks and
they're making their moves in a way
knowing
that they're not being looked at simply
because we don't have the manpower to do
it
that's interesting for you to say that
this they could be coming back so
uh because you know merlino wasn't
something recently with the election
four weeks ago that his name came up
uh that he may have been involved in the
scandal of elections and you know mob's
been involved with elections for god
knows how many years since
dewey days you know way way back with
elections but
you know so so you're saying it's in
their dna you don't think it can change
so you don't think
one of these things about hey you know
i'm a changed man right now i don't have
the same tendency as of trying to get
money out of your pocket and i'm living
a straight life
you think it's something that will never
ever go away once they're in it for 20
30 40 years
listen first of all i commend you for
the hosts the guests that you've had
on your shows i mean you've had some
serious heavyweight guys
i mean sammy the bull i mean come on he
is
he's a bad guy period 19 murders
you know i i mean he's uh he's a tough
guy on the street
you know uh you've had phil leonetti
another one it's i mean these are
serious guys
now have they changed or are they
capable of changing
i don't know it's if you you know what's
the old saying you can't change the spot
of a leopard
are you gonna change this i mean sammy
had his shot to be changed and then he
went into
ecstasy and he got collet so i don't
know i
i hope that they see their light to see
whether it's possible
but would you want to be their next-door
neighbor
i know i would so the answer is you
don't think okay
so so let me let me go back up to a part
where we're talking about we spent a lot
of time with depaul and he was famous
we're talking a lot
was there anybody that he had at this
like a extreme
dislike for from the past in the mob
world
yes there were two people yet one was
nikki corrazzo
okay okay he used to call him the [ __ ]
that was the former boss
little nicky little nicky but he called
him the [ __ ] and then the other one
was a guy that he actually proposed for
membership besides proposing me
he also promoted nicola sorcer now nicky
lasource is a very wealthy guy
his family owns the la source of
chevrolet in the bronx huge huge place
and nikki made a lot of money so when
greg de palma went to jail
he told nikki i want you to go pick up
money
at these places that he has on record
with him
and send it to my wife well nikki was
too busy he had money
he was going to that famous restaurant
in greenwich connecticut where all the
celebrities would go
and he's partying up a storm greg the
palm i'll show you how insane the
mentality is
he gets approached while in jail with
the drug dealer in a wheelchair
it was this guy a spanish drug dealer
from the heights
and he says to him listen if you want me
to take care of this guy
i got a guy that could whack this nicula
sorcerer because he was mother effing
this guy up and down
in prison right so what does he do they
set up a guy to come in
who was an undercover atf agent to meet
with greg de palma
and greg de palma spills out what he
wants this guy to be killed
okay now what happens is greg de palma
gets
charged and like a good criminal that he
is an organized crime
is where they never admit that they're
guilty
it's always like john gotti said you
could catch me with a steeple coming out
of my ass
i did not rob it well the same was greg
de palma the only time he took a plea
was when he was in the scores case and
john gotti told him to take a plea
so he took it because that's the boss
now what happens is
greg is found not guilty
even though overwhelming tapes and
evidence you know
so greg this palmer comes out of prison
and he's trying to reclaim his places
including the strip club that we were at
now that i had infiltrated
okay so now what happens is the fbi is
saying listen
this guy is marked for death he tried to
whack
somebody in fact the fbi went to see
greg the palmer
and says greg you're out of jail we know
have information that you're marked for
death
and greg the palmer says i don't know
what you're talking about don't let the
door hit you in the way out
right and then we're saying okay so i'm
out to lunch with this guy in meetings
and i'm making sure that my back is
facing the wall and i'm watching the
door
because this thing could break any time
i mean you know you start to think maybe
someone's going to go down
well typical greg our surveillance
starts picking up greg
and they see greg the palmer going to
see the bosses
going to see this he's spending time
he's networking like he wouldn't believe
about two weeks later the guy who we
paid the money to keep the albanian says
listen this place is back with greg
or you guys could come with me we chose
greg and the reason why we chose greg is
because he talks so much
you know we're not going to hit your
wagon to a guy named louis villapeli
who is now a captain that was his name
why should i
i put my horse to him what are we going
to get maybe little sponges here and
there
or am i going to hit the mother lode
with greg and that's what we did
but you had i was careful because all
throughout the case
they were saying the boss was saying you
need to sit down with nicola sorcer
and kiss and make up and we finally had
that sit down
where they shook hands and they did it
for the better cause
but if i was nicula's cause i would have
been pissed that this guy
uh try to kill me which he did he
actually set the contract out
interesting very interesting when you
when you're uh uh
talking about who he didn't like and why
he didn't like you know
even the bosses sometimes you hear about
did he ever have any opinions about
the relationship between sammy and gotti
or he never had talked about sami and
gotti
no he never talked about sammy but he
like i said he did love
john gotti he respected him uh sammy no
but
sammy's reputation was always you know
he's a tough guy
sammy i mean uh i was glad by the way
that was an excellent interview with him
and uh
i thought that sammy is the real thing
and now i hear he's got his own show
so that's kind of uh interesting but uh
you know sammy is a guy out there who
you don't want to mess around with you
know and uh now would he go full
gangster on you
i don't know but i certainly will want
to find out you know
if i'm a civilian out there certainly
approaching
and that's one of the interesting thing
you got a guy like that who serves
minimal time in prison
and he's out he could be a next-door
neighbor he could be
having you know you don't know who he is
and boom now i do have a chance i've
spoken to a lot of guys
in the life who cooperated
and are now in the witness protection
program
or left the witness protection program
because they just couldn't handle the
restrictions and the parameters
and some of them are really they they
realize that they and they
all say those who are not happy that
they were betrayed
by cousin austria they betrayed them
and they of course they they mentioned
the reasons for that
and they feel and these are guys whose
family were
part of the of organized crime they grew
up
in that life but they felt like they
were betrayed
and uh their stories are uh you know you
believe that and maybe sammy
his story the way he was betrayed by
john whether that's truth or not but if
obviously if it's true then of course
you have to
you know decide why he broke that or
murder code
because he broke it because it was all
garbage if you're going to lie to me and
you're going to
put me in harm's way for nothing to do
and just so you can get out
now yeah all everything's off the table
then so so you see it from sammy's point
of view just as much as anybody else
anybody uh from gotti's point of view
you mean as far as seeing it from
sammy i think what sammy did is uh it's
not being a rat
i think what sammy did was uh he saved
his life he said hey you know what i did
so much for you
i'm not doing it again now of course
that's a delicate subject
with uh gotti's and uh and sammy the
bull but sammy did make a lot of good
cases for us
in the bureau and provided tremendous
amount of intelligence
now what do you think about when you
think about the name joppa stone what
comes to mind when you think about joppa
stone
well joe was uh i remember i got in the
bureau in 80
and in 81 uh i met joe and i actually
have an
autograph book of his uh joe is like one
of the many
pioneers of undercover there was a
handful of guys
guys like willie reagan paul branagh
eddie rob et cetera
joe is one of them and and keep in mind
people don't understand this but
undercover work is an
investigative scenario just like it is
in surveillance or wiretaps that's all
it is
and sometimes you're lucky sometimes
you're successful other times you're not
other times your original plan snowballs
into a bigger plan
joe being one of the uh
i guess um for lack of brother were
pioneers
of this he was at a time when and i saw
this change in the bureau when i first
started doing undercover
there was nobody watching you 24 7. you
were kind of on your
own you did what you had to do and then
you came back you called the case agent
and you met them and you talked to them
you told them what went on well now
that's changed to
you know you got full coverage on you uh
joe what he did i thought he did an
excellent job with it
uh in that again he's one of the
pioneers him and eddie rob
was another guy that they worked
together in some case
and they set the groundwork for us to to
do these cases
you know so i got a question for you i
asked him i'm curious to know what
you're gonna say about this
i asked uh joe when we did the interview
i said joe
you know i've interviewed other mobsters
and you sound more like you're a mobster
then mobsters sound like they're a
mobster
you dress like one you put the glasses
you're quiet you don't say a lot you
watch you're very
calculating etc etc i said i said
did it ever get to a point because this
is my assumption and i said i want to
hear your answer
i said did it ever get to a point where
you
enjoyed the life too much so much that
you wanted to drag it out where the fbi
finally said you kind of crossed the
line you you could have saw this two
three years ago
but you've dragged this out for six
years because we're under the impression
that you're actually enjoying the life
and uh if you've seen the interview
you'll know what he said but i'm curious
to know
what do you think do you think it got to
a point where maybe joe was enjoying her
life a little bit too much and he didn't
want to get away from it
you know uh i've never experienced that
and i'll tell you why i've
i've worked over a hundred undercover
cases
as well as countless by bus so my career
is i jump from one case to the other
so if you have a case and it's good and
it's give you all the toys i mean i
played everything from
big i've driven rolls royces 500 e
hummers h2s some are h1s i i've driven
all and i've had everything
and for me was like okay you shut it
down
hey maybe you're short-sighted and
shutting it down but i'll move on to
another case
i think joe was one of those guys who
worked maybe a handful of cases
so i don't know the background of why
he want uh to keep it going but my thing
has always been and i've had fights
and in fact if reading my book at the
end i have fights with management
because i've always was trained on the
covers that when you work a case
you walk up the ladder is everything has
to go you try to get as long as you're
gathering evidence as long as
you're pursuing as long as there's
nobody's life at danger
or there are no threats you keep
marching until you can't march anymore
unfortunately in my case after two and a
half years
almost three they pulled the plug for no
reason there was no
nobody didn't believe that i was
anything but jack falcone
my life was not in danger i wish i would
have gotten the five or six years that
joe got
you know so it but it wasn't it was
curtailed for whatever reason
now did that upset me and the united
states attorneys that worked the case
and the case agents absolutely
but what can we do we're just points so
i moved on to another case and did what
i had to do
in hindsight yes the case was successful
we took down
the administration of the post scottie
but
you know i wish we could have more time
i wanted to even go
to the possibility of getting straight
now so i can introduce other agents
uh into the fold and maybe try to get
that 32
into whatever to dismantle the uh the
whole group
so were you ever in it where where jack
were you ever ended when you're like man
i'm
i enjoy this life was there anything
about it that got you enamored where you
were enjoying the life and you didn't
want to leave it
well you know if you talk to people
about i've enjoyed
you have to enjoy working undercover no
matter what you're doing
i mean i've enjoyed flying jet planes
with drug dealers you know i i
all we enjoyed i mean the toys the the
the
the pinky ring the rolex president
watched
the money i used to carry a knot like
five g's in my pocket
now you ask me lucky i got ten dollars
on me you know yes i used to walk in a
restaurant waiters tripped themselves
over to try to take care of big jackie
boy
you know how many do now i get sent to
the bar and wait for my table
you know these are all changes that are
adjusted yes when you're out and
undercover you're acting you take this
persona because you
in order to catch a criminal you have to
think and act like a criminal yep
so you have to play the roles but you
have to also
understand that this is temporary i had
clothes i had senior suits
that were bought with government funds
that i had to return
even my underwear and socks now who is
gonna buy a 66
long suit yes because it's property
so i've learned all my career
i've learned through my career that you
know patrick that
enjoy it go out there enjoy it hey
listen it's
dangerous keep your eyes we used to go
to when i was on the cover
we go to these restaurants we take over
these restaurants that we're in contact
we have five or six wise guys with about
five strippers
you know what i'm saying there was like
champagne was flowing
i mean this is what these guys do you go
out sometimes i went from mani pedis
never had a mani pedi
until i was with the mob you know i had
cucumbers
you know i just think like hillary would
have known what a cucumber was hillary
right
baldwin but anyway that's another story
but yeah
it is seductive it's a seductive
mistress it's something that takes you
over
and you got to be careful because you
it's going to
end and if you think it's going to go on
forever it's not
and if it starts affecting who you are
you better walk away
jack the 26 you were in as an fbi how
many years of it were you married
i got married in 84 so i was
uh listen my wife i think was a saint
let me tell you the success that i think
i've had
okay it's because of her and my daughter
okay they grounded me i even though i
never saw them because i had my own
apartment
very rarely do i saw them it was like
when i spoke to them and even if i
missed a recital even if i missed a
holiday
okay cheating pressure me or get on me
and that's important because you need to
have a clear head
when you're out there with the bad guy
you don't need to have oh my god my
wife's mad at me she's going to leave
she called me
she was very good and i think because
she lived in
with in law enforcement prior to that
with a ference
then i think that's what made the edge
but marriage i've seen this job
patrick where it's affected people's
marriage it's effective their drinking
i've affected all kinds guys have gone
to the dark side
okay the only thing this job did to me
is destroy my weight
my weight i mean i i i have issues
because of that
because i'd learn how to eat but hey
that could be worse you know what i'm
saying
i mean it but it does do something to
you there's a lot of peril
and not too many guys could sustain
undercover the guys who say yeah i
worked undercover what one
two years you know when you're out there
15 years 20 years
you know it's grinding it it does things
to you
you know so you're still married to the
same wife from 1984.
that is correct let me i mean she
deserves a
purple she deserves a medal
she does and my daughter was born in the
year
2000 keep in mind because i was never
home
so yes if you do the math she was 2 000
and then when i left the bureau in 2005
okay i went from driving greg the palmer
a captain in the gambino crime family to
driving
my five-year-old daughter around and
patrick let me tell you there's no
difference
they both want things buy me this get me
that and give me this
non-stop wow wow
you know i i hear these stories and i
think with
stone as well i think he's still married
to the same wife by the way
you know he is still married to the same
wife so it's interesting
both of you guys haven't served as long
as you did and you're still married to
the same woman and you lived a
very difficult life of a person to stay
married to
that is true and it was weird because
when i would come home
those rare moments did she know what she
did she knew what she did she knew i was
in the fbi and of course
i worked undercover no no she didn't
know she didn't know i was working on
the cover because
i would come in to see her you know how
do you explain having an s 500 mercedes
and you know when you're driving a
regular car so
all the toys you know the ring like my
wife would say to me
we got to go to the recital you go there
you look like a gangster you got the
ring the rolex watch
my daughter kept saying i want to take
daddy to show your daddy what she does
at work
what are you going to say yeah my name
is jack falcone i am uh
again an associate in the gambino crime
family
so you you miss and it does stick with
you
being undercover it's very seductive and
i understand why
guys go bad and things have done because
not too many people could could do it or
put up with it
jack you worked undercover with the the
gambino family you worked undercover
with colombians you worked undercover
with mexicans
asians russians which one of them were
the most
ruthless vicious crime family you dealt
with
colombian mexicans uh yeah the organized
crime is a joke when you compare that to
them
these guys are serious it's all about
huge amount of money that the mob never
makes
the violence they not only come after
you patrick they'll come after your
family
i mean they decapitate people they
torture people
when you deal with uh with narcotics and
the cartels
it they just could they could own they
could have them uh the mobsters do their
laundry
in prison i mean they just they're two
separate
the mob has only become in my opinion
the popular because
of this romanticizing of that hollywood
does
of the mob and for some reason people
are loved that
glamour life you know the the good
fellas
but when you're working out there with
these cartels and these people that
are so cunning like for instance when i
met with a lot of people
over drug deals if they pick up a
surveillance
they're gone i mean puff you don't see
them again
they'll wind up somewhere in california
now you're in a surveillance on a wise
guy
you miss him or he's wise to you let me
tell you where he's at
he's at his gummadas house he's at his
wife house
he's at a social club he's with these
other guys playing uh
hooker they're they're predictable
but colombians are not they're more
sophisticated
they're so compartmentalized where if
you take one down
no one knows what the others are so
they're like dixie cups they
just they make money and they get
disposed so
people do ask me that and patrick
there's there's no comparison in my book
uh the cartels
handover fit as far as more violent uh
and ruthless
and treacherous than the mob is or will
ever be
wow they're willing to go places the
other guys aren't
who did you when you were working
undercover did you work with any domain
names in the 80s 90s or 2000s i'm
talking any of the
uh uh el chapo's any of the pablos any
of the medellin families one of the
yeah we work for their people you know
they stayed in colombia of course so we
drove the cartels from
pablo and of course uh all the others
but
we also one of the interesting cases
that really
i've ever had it was a two drug dealers
that were featured twice on 60 minutes
there was the the boys of uh sal
mcgluder and willie falcone
they were the biggest drug traffickers
in florida
and they were successful in not only
killing so many people
they controlled the drug trade and what
they did is we had this undercover case
where i
went in to a guide that uh one of the
jurors
identified as being dirty so we created
a scenario
where i approached him at his work at
the at the airport in miami
and he admitted to
uh taking a bribe of about a million
dollars
and the investigation that led from
there
also identified two other jurors
and those two other jurors this is in a
federal courthouse in miami
also were paid off by sal magluta and
willie falcone
uh really an amazing group and i had to
testify
against sal magluta and i think they got
a hundred and
some odd years willie falcone decided to
uh
uh i think he took a plea on that but
yes those
those are the guys from the 80s those
are the original miami vice guys
you know uh and that to me was probably
one of the roughest guys and then of
course
armando fuentes carrillo those guys from
the mexican cartel
very uh serious players one of the cases
that we worked with dea
was that when the first heroine
that was produced in colombia we were
able to obtain
and what happened in the past the heroin
came from afghanistan
or also came from china so the
cartels brought in a bunch of uh
scientists from china to process
poppy seeds and they started growing it
well
the uh amount the purity amount was
if not the same but higher but the
prices dropped
from like a kilo going for like 150 000
down to 65 and america was flooded
with colombian heroin and that was what
that dea fbi
operation was uh very interesting
because nobody believed that we we had
this tape conversation
with the guy we brought it in and they
said there's no way colombia
is growing poppy and sure enough that's
what it's true did you do anything with
rafa cara quintero or no
no not with quintero okay got it uh you
know there's there's different
communities that will say to follow on
i'm curious to know what your thoughts
are
there are those that will say um
the the the most corrupt organization
we have in america are cops
some will say fbi some will say the mob
some will say others you know who would
you say is the most corrupt amongst
those three and i'm talking the fbi of
today the fbi of the
uh j edgar hoover days you were you know
looked up
you were like cool you were this it's a
different era of fbi today than before
who's more corrupt if you were to say
fbi cops or the
you know mobs or even the government
you know i because i was
an fbi agent and i've seen the men and
women in the fbi
i i can't label them that way you know
uh
uh yes there is this there's corruption
and everything there's corruption in ibm
there's corruption we've handled i did a
lot of dirty cops
in my investment i did five cases of
dirty cops in my case
we've also gotten dirty fbi agents so
yes
they exist but they're a small amount
and thank god that
we police our own that we conduct that
but out of that group i can't
ever say that there is corruption within
the fbi yes there is a bunch of
idiots sometimes that do certain things
that they shouldn't be involved in
we're not a political agency we're just
we're a law enforcement agency
and then the the fact that police
there's also a corruption in that just
like it is with the fbi there's minor
and i think their internal affairs do a
good job so
my thing is always out of those four i
would have to go with organized crime in
any
degree whether it's the mob whether it
is uh
uh the crips the bloods or just uh
asian or russian or whatever you want to
call it so you would put it back on
organized crime
rather than well obviously you're you're
are you a
proud proud fbi agent proud
member of the fbi federal bureau of
investigation
uh yes uh i tell you my problem with
that what i did with the fbi
was good for the fbi but it wasn't good
for jack garcia
you know in hindsight i should have
never done
all this type of work it should have
been somebody who
just stopped it just you shouldn't you
shouldn't be able to have worked so many
cases
and been around all these people and
basically at the end you know yeah
you just sent home you know and uh
so i that that really for me
it's what's the toughest part with the
bureau but i am i do love the bureau i
know there are problems in the bureau
some of it has to do
with management i know i've worked with
some great
managers in the fbi but i've also worked
with people who have no business being
managers
i as an undercover agent throughout the
country because i just didn't work new
york
i did florida san juan puerto rico
philadelphia
from newark i i've run into people that
have no business being bosses
and i've seen it i see where guys even
come up to me as case agents
and here i am and experience undercover
and you get some kid out of quantico
and he's telling you look i wrote the
script out
this is what i want you to say i said
you got to be kidding you're going to
tell me what i got to say just tell me
the parameters so what you got to
accomplish here
i don't know what i'm going to say i
have to look at the person see what
their body language is see if i can go
that extra yard
i said no you say hey dude hey dude i
never used that word
so you're seeing a lot of people who are
i don't know where their training
possibly could have been
but you know the the agents that i work
with were
amazing competent individuals i mean i
worked in a squad just so you know in
queens
which was little columbia we had 15
detectives nypd assigned full-time
and we had 15 agents six of them became
special agents in charge
one of them became an assistant director
the other one is a cnn law enforcement
analyst
so we had the creme de la creme not only
of the fbi
but the nypd these were second and first
grade detectives these guys i go through
any door
i would work anything with them they
were honest as could be
and those are the people that i
gravitated so when i got offered jobs as
an undercover
i just didn't take it as much work as i
went into telling me what the subject
was
i want to know what you as an fbi agent
is because i'm i know i'm going to have
problem with if you're going to cop that
attitude
yeah it's it's interesting you say that
i've sat down with a lot of fbi agents
and one of the things they all have
said most of them have said is at the
end of the
career of the fbi agent they don't take
care of them it's just like hey
great job awesome good luck to you
here's a couple thousand dollars wish
you nothing but the best
versus you know really taking care of
the
life you live being away from everybody
you know it's a form
if you do your job right and you do what
the fbi was
meant to be there for rather than
bullying people around who are just
trying to live their lives
you served a very important purpose very
important purpose to be an fbi agent
you know and and i like the way you put
it you didn't just kind of uh
you know say well no fbi they're all
honorable and they're all this you just
kind of put it out there say there's
good there's bad there's the ugly but
uh mostly what we did was good work that
we did and inside of it there were some
bad people as well
uh and i appreciate you sharing it from
that perspective
by the way you know any any you know
the one story that's always unique to
people is sinatra did any stories of
sinatra how did sinatra
ever make money with the mob and if he
did what was the format how was he used
did he use the mob did they use him
there's a lot of stories i've heard what
did you hear yourself from the palmer
i heard a lot of sinatra and dean
martin's stories uh the classic
uh sinatra story that i heard by the way
he played about four times
at the westchester premiere two of those
were free
and he was scanned by jimmy the weasel
fratiana
what they did was they knew that frank
wasn't impressed with women because he
could get what he wanted
it wasn't about fame and it wasn't about
money
but he loved having awards so they came
up with this plan of creating
the uh the knights of malta maltese
cross
to award it to him so here you go they
they create this fake artifact through
their jewelry contact
and say frank we're going to award you
with this and the knights of
of malta you're going to be a member
it's like a 7 000 year organization has
that
been around that long and absolutely he
bought his mother
the family they gave him the award greg
said
so now the next week they go back to
frank and say hey frank listen
uh knights of malta is so glad to have
you but we're hurting financially
is there a way you could put up a couple
of concerts for us he said
absolutely anything for the knights of
malta so what they do
is they set up these two shows that were
sold out
you know and greg de palma was such a
thief at the westchester premiere
that you would get your ticket and pay
top dollar for what you thought would
seat number one
a which you thought it was the front but
what he did at showtime at the dinner
theater
he put like 10 chairs in front of each
row
so now you were row 11 you were in row
10.
so they sold the place out the money
went into the coffers
of the um organized crime with frank
and actually the story goes that
he when they took that photograph of
carlo gambino and
and all the others doonsberry did a
one of their four panels of tar
is showing that photograph and saying
how that same year frank sinatra
received
the president's award uh i think was
from reagan
and here he is hobnobbing with uh
organized crime
the rumor about him that he vehemently
denied that he was involved
with the mob but he knew all the players
and all the players knew him
and loved him so you wonder sometime was
he
a patron saint of organized crime or was
he a patsy
you know it's you have to figure it out
but the dean martin stories were two
they would come in they would play golf
they'd go out into town
dean did like to party i thought i was
always make-believe what you saw on the
shows but no he enjoyed his cocktails
uh and they would just go out and have a
good time and make a lot of money with
these guys
very cool uh last thing before we wrap
up here you know you got now
michael francis and sammy creating
content on youtube they got channels
they're doing very well i foresee these
channels
uh grown in the millions the way they're
grown what do you think about the
stories you're hearing
whether it's sammy or you're hearing
from michael francis creating content
you know i i actually listened to
sammy's uh
tape i was uh blown away i thought it
was a very nice job the production
i i want i reached out to a couple of
agents and said
boy a lot of these fbi guys spoke are
these recorded
previously and he you know cut and pace
he says no they uh
they provided the the voices you know
and these were
top agents you know and the fbi george
gabriel had
you know uh and the other guy so sammy
has a hook
to get into that so kudos to him you
know what i mean
it's like uh he was able to get these
guys as far as michael
is concerned i i you know that's for
another story patrick i'm not buying it
let's just leave it at that right what
do you mean by that
i'm not buying the religious act but
whatever it is it is you know
god bless him if it's true god bless you
michael you know and uh
i do know his father was a serious
player
i know michael was legit as far as
making money
not legit but he made some serious money
uh in the business i was taken aback a
little by the show
fear uh was a fierce city did you get to
see that show
yeah the the four episodes or six
episodes they had
yeah i don't know how many episodes it
was yes yeah i was taken aback where
they were discussing the hierarchy of
the mob
and they listed the boys the underboss
but
there was no concierge there was like
totally eliminated and michael didn't
even mention and michael should know
because he was in the life they went
from boss under boss
to captains and soldiers so the
concierge
like wasn't even there and then the
other thing he told the story
that i found kind of amazing how he was
telling tony salerno
uh that you know tony salerno asked him
about
hey you're doing good with money why
don't you get together with uh
you know uh get me some of my guys some
jobs so he says yeah i'll get you a
job well how much he says well fifteen
hundreds because fifteen hundred
says give him five hundred and give me
the thousand now
michael franzisi was a columbo okay
tony salerno is genovese west side
if carmine persico found out
that michael is giving jobs to
the genovese crime family instead of
this guys what do you think that would
happen
so you don't think that's possible i
mean don't first of all they were doing
gigs together
many times they would share even the gas
business that was taking place
a lot of the families were working
together so there wouldn't be a massive
feud
but the family your first the way i was
taught in this life
was that your family is your family this
is your first family
yes you all cause an australia
everyone's closer but you
are that is your family so that comes
first
so if you're giving jobs if you're a
combo giving jobs to
gambinos or genovese whomever you're
taking jobs you're taking food from the
table from the other guys
now i was a boss maybe i'm wrong maybe
michael is 100 right but if i was the
boss
and find that out i got an issue with
michael says hey
you know what do you think we're doing
here we got to take care of our guys you
know you
you come to me i'll maybe i have nobody
maybe it's my job
to tell tony's to learn i'm going to
take care of but it ain't your job to do
that
you know it's amazing how much the world
is enamored by mob stories
it is so amazing it is so amazing
they're enamored by the mob stores and i
know you wrote a book
called the making jack falcon which
we're going to put the
link below you wrote this a while back
but obviously the stories are the
stories if anybody
is into the mob stores we're going to
put the link below for people to be able
to order the book
uh jack final thoughts i'm going to
leave it to you what are your final
thoughts here i know you made some
interesting predictions here what what a
lot of people would disagree with you
you said you think the mob is going to
make a comeback
which most people say there's no way in
the world that's going to happen i'll
leave you with the final thoughts
well i tell you i that's just my gut
feeling
and i got a big gut to go with that
so i'll tell you about i just really
believe that this is something that's
going on i mean you
the when you're in the mob you you do
your basic stables which is sports
betting
which is extortion which is loan
sharking that that hasn't stopped
especially during these pandemics you
know loan sharks are making a killing on
these uh things they're people out there
who are looking to make money so as long
as the mob is generating money
there's just no way that they're not
going to grow
exponentially they have to grow and
especially knowing that when they look
in their review mirror
the feds are not going to be behind them
they're going to start looking to do so
and listen they're also
constantly morphing one of the biggest
stories that
you should have uh talk about one day is
the fact that the gambino crime family
perpetrated the biggest internet fraud
case ever
to the tune of nearly a billion dollars
and that's with
locatio richie martino
andrew campos who is now is still a
captain
and then you have seth mustafa these
guys created a bank
and then they were tapping into all the
cell phones that we had
where they had all these extra billing
50 cents here 50 there
they made all of that money coupled with
800 numbers dial so as you could see
these guys by the way they did five
years for this can you imagine that
five years for a billion dollars where's
that line form
you know so but these guys are out there
they're always morphing they're moving
in directions
that they want to um you know
to make money so it's no longer the
traditional
mud it's wherever there is money to be
made you're gonna find them up
they'll be back like like arnold said
they'll be back the mob will be back
well we will be watching closely to see
if they'll be back
but uh uh jack thank you so much for
being a guest and sharing your stories
man i really enjoyed it
likewise thank you so much patrick i
really there's a an honor all the best
my friend
take care okay you know what i like
about this one is the fact that here's
an undercover fbi agent from the era of
and on because piston when i did the
interview was 80
uh 76 to 81 and you get some of the
stories after that but this is a
different era
and a completely different perspective
of how the story was told
but uh i'm curious to hear your thoughts
what you took away from it comment below
and if you enjoyed this interview i have
two other interviews i want you to watch
one of them is with joe pastone
aka donny brosco if you've never watched
that it's a legendary it's long it's a
couple hours
or you can watch michael mcgowan another
fbi agent who's got an incredible story
of what he had to do
and he his dealing went with sicily
undercover calling negotiating with a
boss and acting tough
a very different story that he had and
on some questions when i pushed him he
got a little bit uncomfortable
didn't want to answer but he gave me
enough information for you to be able to
enjoy
the interview that i did with him so
either one pick on uh click on these
interviews to watch them
and with that being said take care
everybody bye bye bye